and now I'm so pleased to introduce a
woman that I've had the pleasure of
working with in two films she's an Oscar
winner she's beautiful
rare screen presence and everyone who
knows her loves her Goldie Hawn
there is one group of highly talented
men and women in film whose contribution
requires that they not call attention to
themselves they are the composers people
who supply the music that invisibly
heightens and brightens every key scene
in a film and the nominees for Best
Original Score are the patriot by John
Williams
pouching Tiger Hidden Dragon bite and
hoon milena by Ennio Morricone gladiator
by Hans Zimmer Chocolat by Rachel
Portman and the Oscar goes to Tandon
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Tan Dung he's also
nominated for original song tonight for
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
I've prepared something exactly 45
seconds my music is to dream without
boundaries
tonight with you I see boundaries being
crossed as a classical music composer
I'm thrilled to be honored here
Crouching Tiger breached east and the
West
romance and action high and low cultures
Thank You Ann Lee yo-yo ma
Peter Gelb Michael Gough and James
Sheamus peel calm Thank You Sony
Classical kami and G shimmer for
day-long support last this is for two
tigers in my family my wife Jane Ian
some pose born in the year of Tigers
Thank You Academy
next Oscar winner Anthony Hopkins Winona
Ryder John Travolta and the remarkable
performance by Oscar nominee fjord